who have been baptized today next week
when you come back you will join our new
believers class so that you will be
nurtured for different levels of classes
so that we will know more what we are
talking here what we have been telling
everyone and how we can prepare for the
coming of the king okay if you have
worries Marybel and Mika if you have
written any question already then we can
we can receive it oh they need more
papers here on this side
so let me know
yeah
so we will ask our young people to
please look around and say or you raise
your hand if you have your your papers
ready so that we can start reading the
questions and we can start asking pastor
Andy to have the answers for all these
questions I think we have a first
question and he has not written it so
that we can start mr. colossian this is
the first time I will just let you talk
the rest are all should be written thank
you Pastor good afternoon everyone
actually I had two questions but the
first question is just a yes-or-no from
the Old Testament and the second is from
the New Testament from the Old Testament
the from the doctrine of sanctuary of
course I would not I like to know the
five pillars of the sanctuary the
meaning of course the blood step the
time the blood is the death of Christ
but my concern is the are the five
pillars what does it mean my answer is I
will let confirmed to pass around this
right the five pillars are the five box
Moses or the Torah that's only yes or no
the second question is we said that in
the first century the Apostle Peter was
permitted to to raise the dead and why
today there was no more better to
resonate and if there is we should is it
possible the first century apostles
better was permitted to
resurrect dead like like you know
gazelle or tabatha she was raised to
life during a time of the proposal but
today is there no chance that such
raising the dead can happen
Thank You Buster do you want to answer
that
let's pray our Father in heaven James
chapter 1 verse 5 says if any of you
lack wisdom let him ask of God grant me
wisdom father as I attempt to answer
these questions that in the giving of
the information your name may be
glorified and your people may be
enlightened in Jesus name we pray amen
the question I believe is in the first
century of the Christian Church Peter is
a dead person
Dorcas I believe it was Paul raise your
cuffs who fell from a window Paul was
preaching so long he fell asleep on the
boy fell does that why is that not
happening today now we don't know if
it's not happening we just don't know
but when the latter rain falls which is
even more power than the former rain we
have no clue what God will allow us to
do so when the latter rain falls the
power will be greater than it was in the
New Testament church under the early
rain so we can expect that these things
will happen whenever I cannot say they
do not happen because I don't know but I
do know that when the latter rain falls
which is greater power than the Apostles
had these things may happen all right
thank you god bless you were you the one
playing the violin
this is the next question what is the
relationship between our diet and
spirituality
oh there's every connection between diet
and spirituality the first atom fell on
the question of diet the second atom
concurred on the question of diet diet
and spirituality are cannot be separated
many of us we struggle with things that
are the result of the way we eat I'll
never forget someone wrote me and said I
have strong sexual addictions but I have
no sexual addiction counselor but my
first recommendation was give up meat
and the person did that for about six
weeks and wrote back and said to me I am
amazed at how this fiery passion has
subsided since I gave up me in the
United States the most the number one
preventable cause of death today is
lifestyle it used to be smoking now it
is lifestyle God arranged for people to
eat before sin in the new world we will
also eat eating and spirituality cannot
be separated the fixed commandment says
thou shalt not kill many people kill
themselves with their mouths are you
following me we eat ourselves to death
by the things we eat and how much we eat
so the sixth commandment which is the
source of the health laws because when a
Bible says thou shalt not kill it means
as well don't kill yourself and we kill
ourselves by the way we eat that's why a
Leviticus 11 we have instructions
regarding what to eat and to show you
how important eating is in Leviticus
from
chapter about 11 about 15 they are
varying kinds of uncleanness if you had
leprosy that was the worst kind of
uncleanness if there was mold on your
dress that was unclean if there was mold
in your house that was unclean dandruff
was considered unclean if a man had a
nocturnal emission that was unclean and
of course animals were unclean now
listen to this of all the forms of
uncleanness all of them could be treated
except unclean animals there was nothing
that could be done to make an unclean
animal clean so when God said don't eat
unclean foods it's not just for the Jews
or just for their era is for all
generations for all nations let me say
again all forms of uncleanness could be
reversed by certain rituals except the
uncleanness of animals and this goes all
the way back before the flood in Genesis
7 verse 1 the Bible says under Lord said
unto Noah come thou and all thy house
into the ark for thee have I seen
righteous before me in this generation
of every clean beast thou shalt take to
thee by 7 the male and the female and of
every beast every does not clean by 2
the male and the female so we had
unclean and clean even before the flood
came in in 3rd John verse 2 beloved I
wish above all things that I may prosper
and be in health if you read Isaiah 58
which talks about the mission of the
church when we do what's right the Bible
says then shall I help spring forth like
the morning so health is associated with
spirituality you cannot separate the two
that's why the health message is part of
the thuringiensis message
check
these three questions are related what
is the importance of the holy spirit
okay when are we pull up the Holy Spirit
uh-huh and how do we feel the presence
of the whole is all right what is the
importance of the Holy Spirit what's the
third second one once the importance of
the Holy Spirit right there or is it
here okay when are we Phil and how do we
operate since the Holy Spirit is
absolutely essential go to Romans
chapter eight Romans eight we're talking
about the Holy Spirit Romans eight what
is the importance of the Holy Spirit
when are we filled with the Holy Spirit
how do we know we filled with the Holy
Spirit Romans eight let's read from
first one the Bible there's therefore
now no condemnation to them which are in
Christ Jesus who walk not after the
flesh but after the spirit for the law
of the spirit of life in Christ Jesus
hath made me free from the law of sin
and death for what the law could not do
in that it was weak through the flesh
God sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh and for sin condemned
sin in the flesh that the righteousness
of the law might be fulfilled in us who
walk not after the flesh but after the
spirit for there that of the flesh do
mind the things of the flesh they that
are of the spirit the things of the
spirit for the be carnally minded is
death but to be spiritually minded is
life and peace because the carnal mind
is enmity against God for it is not
subject to the law of God neither indeed
can be so that they that are in the
flesh cannot please God now when you
receive that in the flesh cannot please
God what's the other side of that they
that are in the
spirit as the only ones who please God
now read verse 9 but ye are not in the
flesh but in the spirit if so be that
the Spirit of God dwell in you finish
verse 9 now if any man have not the
Spirit of Christ he is none of his the
only way you can belong to God is if the
Spirit of Christ dwells in us go to
verse 14 for as many as are led by the
Spirit of God they are the sons of God
go to verse 16
what is verse 16 say the spirit itself
beareth witness with our spirit that we
are the children of God it is the
presence of the Spirit in us that
testifies to the fact that we are the
children of God now go to Genesis
chapter 1 we'll read from verse 1 we
answer the question what is the
importance of the Holy Spirit Genesis 1
reading from verse 1 the Bible says in
the beginning God created the heaven and
the earth and the earth was without form
and void and darkness was upon the face
of the deep now you read the rest and
the Spirit of God moved upon the face of
the waters the first member of the
Godhead mentioned by name in the Bible
is the holy spirit now let us go to John
14 let's read verse 6 John 14 4:6 I am
thankful for that question whoever sent
it is a fundamentally important question
what is the importance of the Holy
Spirit do you have John 14 4 6 what does
it say jesus said what I am the way the
truth and the life jesus said I am three
things the way the truth and the life
unless you're the first John chapter
five reading verse six
first John five or six have you found it
not yet so I'm used to looking first
John 5 verse six do you have it now
alright read with me what does it say
this is he that came by water and blood
even Jesus Christ not by water only but
by water and blood finish the verse and
it is the spirit that beareth witness
come on because the Spirit is truth now
what did we read about Jesus in John
14:6 he is truth and the Spirit is truth
now if the Spirit is what Jesus is then
that tells immediately there is an
equality between Jesus and the spirit
now let's go back to John 14:6 Jesus
says I am the way the truth and the life
let's go back to Romans chapter 8 let's
see if we can find out if the Spirit is
life john romans 8 reading from verse 1
we're answering the question what is the
importance of the holy spirit when you
found Romans 8 say mmm
there's therefore now no condemnation to
them which are in Christ Jesus who walk
not after the flesh but after the spirit
read with me now for the law of the word
spirit of life in Christ Jesus hath made
me free from the law of sin of death and
so we have the spirit of life and Jesus
says he is life so Jesus says I am the
truth the Bible says the Holy Spirit is
the truth Jesus says I am the life the
Bible calls the Holy Spirit the spirit
of life Jesus says I am the way now is
the spirit the way let's go to Galatians
chapter 5 Galatians 5 read verse 24
Galatians 5:24 you have that read for me
what is it saying
nice a lot if you have the King James
Version
now first 25 if we live in the spirit
let us also walk in the spirit read
verse 16 say that again
walk in the spirit you shall not fulfill
the lusts of the flesh to walk in the
spirit means that the spirit is the way
so Jesus is the way the spirit is the
way Jesus is a life this spirit is the
life Jesus is truth this spirit is truth
go to John 3 John chapter 3
we read in verse eight
John three reading verse eight when you
found this amen
okay let my brother find it John three
verse eight
now this is a very important first
giving us information about the Holy
Spirit are you ready the wind bloweth
where it listeth and thou hearest the
sound thereof but canst not tell whence
it cometh or whither it goeth finish the
verse so is every one that is born of
the Spirit
what is Jesus referring to when he says
born of the Spirit the new birth
conversion and who what agent carries
out conversion the Holy Spirit Jesus
says so is every one that is born of the
Spirit why did I have you read that
verse only a divine being can bring
about conversion you didn't hear what I
said the Holy Spirit must be a divine
being if he is the one that brings about
conversion because conversion is
salvation here's what the Bible says in
Isaiah 45 first 22 go there with me
Isaiah 45 first 22 and I'm gonna take a
long time on this question because it is
so important and God bless whoever sent
that question Isaiah 45 will read verse
22 iyslah is called the gospel prophet
when you found it's a male read with me
what does they say look unto me and be
saved all the ends of the earth keep
reading for I am God and there is none
else now I want you to think listen
again I'll say the first you listen look
unto me and be what saved all the ends
of the earth for I am God and there is
none else what is God trying to say when
he says there's none else there's no one
else
listen to the first listen to the first
look unto me and one so what's this
what's the heart and soul of that first
salvation now the verse end for I am God
and there is none else what is God
saying in that verse no one else can
save but God are you with me
go to verse 18 are you ready with me
for thus saith the Lord that created the
heavens God Himself that formed the
earth and made it he FS tablished it he
created it not in vain he formed it to
be inhabited now notice how the verse
ends but before we read the end of the
first give me one word describing what
we've read so far listen to the verse
listen microscopically listen thus saith
the Lord that created the heavens God
Himself that formed the earth and mainly
he hath established it he created a not
in vain he formed it to be inhabited
give me one word that describes what we
just read creation think now listen to
how the verse ends for I am the Lord and
there is none else what is he saying
there's no one else who can create so in
verse 18 only God can create in verse 22
only God can save but Jesus tells us in
John 3:8 we are converted by the power
of the Holy Spirit then the Holy Spirit
must be refined
go to Isaiah 46 read verse 9 and first
10 we're answering the question what is
the importance of the holy spirit isaiah
46:9 and 10 are you ready read with me
remember the walk
former remember what a fool I am God and
there is none else I am God
there's none likely stop why is God
saying I am God
there's none else read first M declaring
the end from the beginning and from
ancient times the things that are not
yet done stock one is God seeing he
alone can do come on
declaring the end from the beginning was
that he alone knows the beginning from
the end now keep this in mind we've
discovered only God can save only God
can create only God knows the beginning
and the end
go to Psalm 104 Psalm 104 we discovered
the Holy Ghost transforms us he saves
they have Psalm 104 read verse 29 the
first part carefully read verse 30
now send this forth thy spirit they are
created the Spirit is involved in
creation God creates the spirit create
God saves this spirit saves God knows
the end from the beginning let's find
out if the Holy Ghost knows the end from
the beginning go to first Peter chapter
1 first be the one when I tell you read
with me I can hardly hear you
it is because we have 200 different
versions if you have mine please read I
love to hear the church reading 1st
Peter 1 reading from first 10 read might
concentrate as you read concentrate of
with salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched diligently who
prophesied of the grace that are coming
to you now read carefully searching what
or what manner of time the Spirit of
Christ which was in
them did signify when it testified
beforehand the sufferings of Christ and
the glory that should be revealed now
the Bible says the Old Testament
prophets were led by the Spirit of
Christ and they spoke of things that
hadn't happened for hundreds of years
now look at verse 11 again read their
first again read with me what does it
say searching what and what manner of
time the Spirit of Christ which was in
them did signify or tell them when they
testified the sufferings of Christ and
the glory that should follow okay now
how long of a span is that look at the
prophets question for you who is the
first prophet in the Bible Enoch Enoch
now put your thinking caps on where do
we read about Enochs prophecy in dude
let's go to choose the book just before
revelation we're still answering the
question what is the importance of the
holy spirit and I want you to understand
the Holy Spirit is a divine being
Julia reading from verse 14 when you
found out say mmm
I assume you still looking for Jude Jude
by the way was a half-brother of Christ
Christ had another half-brother who
wrote a book of the Bible what was his
name James do you have q14 read with me
and Enoch also the seventh from Adam
prophesied of these saying behold the
Lord cometh with ten thousands of his
Saints to the world to execute judgment
now stop that's enough
Enoch said the Lord cometh with ten
thousands of his Saints to execute
judgment upon all now what was he not
referring to when he said that the Lord
cometh with ten thousands of his Saints
not the first coming because of the
first coming
he did not come to execute judgment
Jesus said for God sent not his son into
the world to condemn the world but that
the world through him might be saved he
did not come with ten thousand Judas
referring in or both the second and the
third now yes
and the third because at the third
coming he's coming back that's when he
waits that the the sinful dead shows
them their lives and then destroys now
it has been six notice the verse says
and Enoch the seventh from Adam meaning
or let me say this Enoch and Adam lived
together for many years
that tells you how far back Enoch was
prophesying are you following me 6,000
years since Adam - four thousand six
Adam 2006 Christ
less it has six thousand maybe five
thousand Adam lived 930
the Millennium is how long a thousand so
Jude Enoch is prophesying something from
the days of Adam that will happen over a
thousand years beyond our time he is
giving the beginning to the end but
where did he get it the Holy Spirit
firstly the one first Allah
the Spirit of Christ which was in them
in all the prophets including Jew and
anak I am trying to show you the Holy
Ghost could tell Enoch what would happen
thousands of years beyond Enoch lifetime
because the Holy Spirit is a divine
being we've discovered the Holy Spirit
can save the Holy Spirit can create the
Holy Spirit knows the end from the
beginning the Holy Spirit is life the
Holy Spirit is the way the Holy Spirit
is truth there's something else for the
Holy Spirit you need to understand go to
Acts chapter 13 will read from first one
acts 13 reading from first one very
interesting passage the first four
verses of that chapter very significant
do you have x13
if you have my version read from first
one was they say now there was in the
church that was at Antioch certain one
fossils and preachers and teachers as
home Barnabas and Simon little cognition
and Lucius of Cyrene II and Malayan
which have been brought up with Herod
the Tetrarch and Saul five men are
mentioned prophets and teachers now keep
us in mind next verse as they did one
minister to the Lord and fasted you keep
up the reading now the Holy Ghost said
What did he say separate me Barnabas and
Saul for the work we're unto I have
called them a lot of people say the Holy
Ghost is not a being he's this
electricity or energy energy cannot
discriminate between personalities the
Holy Ghost looks at a Barbara Barnabas
Simon condition Lucius of Cyrene Manaen
and saw he looks at five and he said I
want
and Saul I have appointed a work for
them that's a personal being I tell you
something else or the Holy Ghost go to
1st Corinthians 2 I am so happy for this
question I love to talk about the Holy
Ghost he is the invisible man in the
Godhead 1st Corinthians 2 we read 9 and
10 remember think think
as you read read microscopically have
you found 1st Corinthians 2 reading from
verse 9 familiar first read for me what
does it say but as it's written I have
not seen nor ear heard neither have
entered into the heart of man the things
which God hath prepared for them that
love him now read first 10 come on
but God hath revealed them to us how by
his Spirit keep reading for the spirit
searcheth water stop the spirit searches
what all think now we have to ask which
all things he willing yea the deep
things of God now the Greek word for
search is to examine and understand
profoundly to have a profound
understanding the Bible says the Holy
Ghost lost everything God knows now you
tell me how can the Holy Ghost know
everything God knows unless the Holy
Ghost is also defined only a divine
being can know everything another divine
being knows my brothers and sisters
there's a movement in the Adventist
Church to destroy the Trinity teaching
the Holy Ghost the Father the Son 3i
individual personalities but they're one
in heart in mission and go to John
you Chapter three now let's go to John
14 let me show you again this time the
Holy Ghost plus the father and the son
John 14 let's read from verse 16 John 14
reading from verse 16 when you found
that say Amen if you're still looking
say mmm okay hurry up hurry up
okay are you ready
read with me and I will pray the Father
now who is I Jesus who is the father to
whom is Jesus praying to the father two
beings are you following me I will pray
the father follow me now and he shall
give you what another comforter who's
there the comforter even the Spirit of
Truth stop here's Jesus pray come on to
the father that the father might give
what the Holy Spirit three beings
go to Matthew 3 Matthew chapter 3 this
is the baptism of Jesus Christ
now you found Matthew three let's read
from from sixteen what does it say and
Jesus when he was baptized went up
straightway out of the water he
breathing carefully and lo the heavens
were opened unto Him now where is Jesus
coming out of the River Jordan and lo
the heavens were opened unto him and he
saw one now Jesus saw something he
didn't see himself he saw something
coming from where out of heaven he saw
the Spirit of God descending like a dove
and lighting upon him this is a separate
entity so we have Jesus coming out
he looks here comes a dove the Holy
Spirit can take any form he took the
form of cloven tongues of fire in Acts
chapter 2 verse wonderful the only ghost
sits there in the form of a dove now
verse 17 and lo come on a voice from
where heaven stop where was Jesus come
on on the earth where was the Holy Ghost
on the earth where did the voice come
from in heaven we have Jesus coming out
of the water he sees he's the witness to
an entity descending from heaven in the
form of a dove the Bible says as the
Holy Ghost sits on him then both of them
hear a voice from heaven which says this
is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased we have Jesus we have the Holy
Spirit and we have the father my friends
there's the Father the Son the Holy
Ghost now there is much about them we
don't understand because a human being
cannot fully understand a divine being
but the Bible gives us enough
information to believe there are three
beings father son Holy Ghost now they
have different functions are you
following me let's go to John 14 John 14
John 14 let's read verse 28 try to
understand how the members of the
Godhead function John 14 reading first
28 are you ready read with me nice and
clear you've heard how I said I go away
and come again unto you if he loved me
you would rejoice because I walk I go
into the father for my father come on
say it again
my father now what did Jesus mean if
they all divine how can a father be
greater than the son let us go to John
13 John 13 I think the verse is 16 you
let me know John 13 what is 416 saying
verily verily I say unto you the servant
come on is not greater than his Lord
read very carefully keep reading neither
is he come on read sent greater than he
that sent him now the verse has two
people the one who sent and the one who
sends he looked at me as though I am
speaking a foreign language do you see
that in a verse there are two people the
one who sends and the one who sent the
first says verily verily I say unto you
the servant is not greater than his Lord
finish the verse neither is he that is
said come on read greater than he that
sent him what is Christ saying the one
who sends is greater than the one who is
sent go to John 15
Reavers 20 John 15 verse 20 what does
that say remember the word that I what's
the word tell us now this server is not
greater than his Lord stop now here's
the father here's the son follow me
closely
who sent home the father sent the son so
with respect to authority who is greater
the father because Jesus says the one
who sins is greater than the one who is
sent but let's look at the earthly
analogy here's the server here's the
master who is greater because the master
sends a servant but which one is more
human which one is more human they're
the same the master is as human as the
servant you look at me strangely they're
equally human but the master has great
award Authority here's Jesus here's the
father they are fully divine but the
father has greater authority go to John
829 Johnny 29 I know I know
I am taking along on this question but
the goalie goes I believe is leading me
it is so significant John 829 listen to
Jesus are you ready
start reading and he then have sent me
stop you notice sent me there we have it
there it's all over John eda have sent
me it's with me the father hath not left
me alone
finish the verse for I do always those
things that please him
question for you how long has Jesus been
doing the things that please the father
only when he came to the earth
from way back do you know creation was
the work that Jesus did at the direction
of the Father you didn't understand me
Jesus created for the father he did what
the father said you really fishin's
three for standing and to make all men
see what is the Fellowship of the
mystery which from the beginning of the
world have been hidden God who created
all things through Jesus Christ yes
Christ was the means by which the father
created the same way Christ is the means
by which the father gave himself I
wanted you to see Christ has always
obeyed the father's commands way back
before the world was made so when he
said I do always the things he did not
just mean on earth because when he spoke
to the Pharisees in John 8:56 he said
before Abraham was I am John 8:58 he was
telling the Pharisees I go way back the
father is greater than the Son and the
son has more authority than the Holy
Ghost let's look at that go to John 14
read verse 26 John 14 and I may have to
call an individual to read for me to
finally hear what you're saying John 14
verse 26 are you there
all right slow down okay dr. April John
14 verse 26 as they tried to slow down
are you ready read verse 26 to John 14
but the comforter which is the Holy
Ghost which the father shall send in my
name stop that verse says the father can
send the Holy Ghost in the name of Jesus
is that clear yes or no go to John 15:26
John 15:26 read for me now when the
comforter is come whom I will send to
you from the father stop what do you
notice who sends the comforter in John
14:26
the father who sends the comforter in
John 15:26 Jesus which means both Jesus
and the father can give commands of the
Holy Ghost now when Christ was on the
earth in his human form the Holy Ghost
directed him when Christ went back to
heaven
it was Christ who ordered the Holy Ghost
to bring all those spiritual gifts and
the gift of tongues the Holy Ghost came
at the direction of the Sun now he's
gone back he's on the right hand of the
Father let me said again as I slowed
down when Christ lived as a human being
he was directed by the Holy Spirit and
he said the Spirit of God is upon me
because he hath anointed me to preach
the gospel to the poor Luke 4:18 but
when he went back assumed his position
now the Holy Ghost took direction from
him so here's what we have as far as
this substance they are all divine
father son Holy Ghost but as far as
authority and office you turn the
fingers that way father son Holy Ghost
is that clear let me say it again this
is how they are the father's divine the
Holy Ghost is a vine the son the son is
divine the Holy Ghost is defined when it
comes to responsibilities and office and
funk
the father highest then the son then the
Holy Ghost now here's the father here's
the mother here's a child are you with
me which one is more human they're all
equally human but when it comes to
Authority we have the father the mother
the child is that clear
all right the Holy Spirit is divine
he is part of a family of three now the
most frightening thing about a Holy
Spirit
let's read it Matthew 12 reading from
verse 31 Matthew 12 reading from verse
31 it's almost what 40 minutes have been
on this question but it's important
Matthew 12 reading verse 31 do you have
it
read for me nice and clean let me
understand the words you're saying start
reading
wherefore saying to you uh-huh all
manner of st. aha
very nice shall be forgiven and two men
keep reading but the blasphemy against
the Holy shall not be forgiven unto man
keep reading and whosoever speak if a
word against the holy AHA it shall
offend the Son of Man it shall be Kiwi
lame
but whoever speaketh against the Holy
Ghost it shall not be forgiven him
neither in this world neither in the
world to come wait a minute
the body will says you blaspheme Christ
there's forgiveness finish my words you
blaspheme the Holy Ghost there's no
forgiveness now clearly they must be
equal in substance you understand you
can be less famed Jesus and there's
forgiveness available you blaspheme the
Holy Ghost
there's none which means father son Holy
Ghost the most sensitive member of the
Godhead is the Holy Ghost so we have to
be very careful how we talk about him
and stop calling him energy and
electricity and sound waves whatever
rubbish people call the Holy Ghost the
Holy Ghost is an intelligent divine
being and when he's offended I don't
want to be in your shoes all right let
me quiz you in John 14:6 Jesus says
three things about himself without
looking tell me what the three things
are he's the way the truth we discovered
the Holy Ghost as though the truth and
the life we discovered in Isaiah 45
22 isaiah 45:18 isaiah 46:9 and 10 that
only God can save only God can create
only God knows the end from the
beginning and we found out is the Holy
Ghost who brings about conversion the
Holy Ghost was sent he was involved in
creation and the Holy Ghost told the
prophets what would happen thousands of
years before it happened
what God can do the Holy Ghost can do
what the son can do the Holy Ghost can
do because all three are equally defined
but in the area of office and
responsibilities father's highest then
son then Holy Spirit the Bible says if
any man have not the Spirit of Christ
he's none of his now the second question
was how do we get the Holy Spirit
let's find three ways to get the Holy
Spirit
the easy way let's go to Matthew 11
Matthew 7 for a less read verse 11 of
Matthew 7 let's read verse 11 I may not
get to any other question this is too
important for me to take time from this
I just feel led to stay on this question
what book did I say Matthew what chapter
what first just as clearly as you read
just now read now again start reading
King James Version if a then being evil
know how to give good gifts unto your
children stop let me just digress even
evil people can make right decisions you
didn't hear what I said
listen to Jesus if a then being evil
know how to give good gifts so you can't
tell God well I was so bad no no no even
in your badness you have some sense of
what's good what's not good if a then
being evil know how to give good gifts
unto your children finish the verse how
much more read again how much more shall
your which is in heaven come on give
now let's look at that verse carefully
good things is that singular or plural
plural
Jesus says your heavenly Father knows
how to give what good things now many
things now Luke will give us some
explanation of what Matthew meant
remember we did that this morning with
binding and loosing look now gives us
the same speech but it changes the word
slightly let's go to Luke 11 let's read
verse 14 Luke 11 verse 14 Matthew said
the father knows how to give good things
many good things Luke 11 verse 14 13 13
what is that saying
if Ethan being evil know how to give
good gifts unto your children how much
more shall your walk heavily father give
what the Holy Spirit to them that ask ah
let's combine the two Matthew says the
father knows how to give good things
many good things Luke says the best of
the lot is the Holy Ghost you're not
with me yes Matthew says many good
things
Luke identifies one as the best the Holy
Spirit and then he tells us ask then you
want the Holy Spirit what should you do
ask now that's one condition let's look
at the second condition Acts chapter 5
let's read verse 31 and 32 well first 32
of Acts 5 how do I get the Holy Spirit
acts 5:32
are you ready
are you sure read with me and we are his
witnesses of these things and saw is
also whom the holy ghost finish the
verse whom God hath given to them that
obey Him uh-huh
what's my favorite word obey the Bible
gives us true condition so far if you
want the Holy Ghost what should you do
ask what else should you do obey God
there's another one go to Acts chapter 2
Acts chapter 2 have you found it now
Peter is delivering the sermon on the
day of Pentecost powerful sermon in
verse 37 the Bible says read with me now
when they heard this they were pricked
in their heart and said unto Peter
you're not reading with me enter the
rest of the Apostles men and brethren
finish the verse what should we do read
verse 38 clearly and microscopically we
did go ahead then Peter said unto them
walk repent and be baptized every one of
you in the name of Jesus Christ for the
remission of sins and ye shall receive
come on the gift of the Holy Ghost now
we have three conditions named them do
you want the Holy Ghost number one
number two number three get baptized are
these my words or are you reading the
Bible mm-hmm all right let me tell you
something else about the Holy Spirit go
to Genesis chapter 6 Genesis 6 will read
from first one our subject how to get
the Holy Ghost that's the subject of
this sermon god is good
all right and all the time do you see
bomb total orator ahora there are mean
okay
what what did I say Genesis what Chapter
six really from what first one read with
me please nice people and it came to
pass when men began to multiply on the
face of the earth and daughters were
born to them that the sons of God saw
the daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose we carefully now and the Lord
said what my spirit shall not always
strive with man for that he also has
flesh yet is there shall be 120 years
the Bible introduces the Holy Ghost as
the power that can fix us it is the Holy
Ghost that convicts you you're wrong but
you know what he uses to convict the
word and when you condense the word you
know what you get down to if you take
the word and boil it and boil it until
it comes down to a little thing in the
bottle in the bottom of that kettle you
know what that is the 10 commandments
the entire Bible teaches us how to live
up to God's law so the Holy Ghost
convicts us by the application of the
word to the heart my spirit shall not
always strive with man my brothers and
sisters what we need more than anything
else in these last days is the Spirit of
God go to John 16 let's wave from first
seventy we're looking at the Holy Ghost
again John 16 reading from verse 7 it's
25 to 4
John 16 reading from first seven when
you found it say mmm those of you who
loved Jesus read nice and Claire what
does it say nevertheless I tell you the
truth it is expedient for you that I go
away for if I go not away the comforter
will not come unto you but if I depart I
will send him unto you now read
carefully and when he's come come on he
will reprove the world of sin of
righteousness and of judgment stop he
will reprove or convict the world of sin
that's the problem of righteousness
that's the solution of judgment where
the decision will be made between those
who accepted righteousness or those who
lived in sin when he's come here reprove
the world of sin righteousness of
judgment okay of sin because they
believe not on me of righteousness
because I go to my father and he see me
no more of judgment because the prince
of this world is judge
now let's read verse 13 howbeit Oh less
3:12 I have yet many things to say into
you but she cannot bear them now keep
reading how did it when he the Spirit of
Truth is calm you tell me the rest he
will guide you into all truth stop never
read the Bible without praying for the
Holy Ghost if you do do that you will
guide yourself into one era the Holy
Ghost guides us into truth he will guide
you into all truth for he shall not
speak of himself that doesn't mean he
doesn't talk about him it means he does
not speak of his own authority but
whatsoever he shall hear whether from
the son or a father that shall he speak
and he will show you things to come if
the Holy Ghost will show you things to
come no need to go to the witchdoctor
nobody's listening to me the Holy Ghost
will tell you what you need to know he
will show you things to come save your
money
give it to the church not the
witchdoctor read verse 14 for me now
come on verse 14
he shall do what glorify me for he shall
receive of mine and show it unto you
stop he shall receive of mine but is the
truth as it is in Jesus or the gifts he
shall receive of mine and shew it unto
you verse 15
all things that the father has are mine
therefore said I that he shall take of
mine and it is the Holy Ghost that
decides who gets what gift let's see
that more clearly stated 1st Corinthians
let's read from verse 8 how do we get
the Holy Ghost we're looking at what he
does then we'll get to how do we know we
have the Holy Ghost
1st Corinthians 12 let's read from verse
8 you have first Corinthians 12 reading
from verse 8 some of you are doing very
well with your reading I'm so grateful
read with me now what does it say 4 to 1
is given by the spirit the word of
wisdom stop the Spirit gives wisdom to
another the word of knowledge by the
same spirit stop and the list goes all
the way to the first and to another
faith now it is the spirit that gives
the gifts but at the direction of Christ
and the Father the gifts in the church
are given by the Spirit of God and he
decides who gets which gift okay how do
we know we have the spirit let us go to
Exodus 31 now reason with me please
Exodus 31
you have Exodus 31 verse 18 and he gave
unto Moses when he admit an end of
communing with him about Mount Sinai two
tables of testimony finish the verse
tables of stone written how with the
finger of God keep us in mind the law
was written on the stone with the finger
of God let us go to Luke 11 Luke 11 and
I want you to reason based on the verses
I'm giving you we just read the law is
written with the finger of God Luke 11
verse 20 now price had cast out a demon
and he was accused of using the power of
Satan and Christ is defending himself
now read verse 28 of Luke 11 what does
that say but if I with the finger of God
come on cast out devils know that the
kingdom of God is come upon you Jesus
says if I cast out Devils by the finger
of God now what does that mean that's
the same finger that wrote the
commandments now this time let laughs
you explain Luke twice today we had Luke
explaining Matthew now listen to Matthew
explaining what Luke meant by the finger
of God Matthew 12 reading verse 28
Matthew is dealing with the same
incident but he uses a different word
and gives us light Matthew 12 28 when
you found it say Amen read with me what
does it say but if I cast out devils how
by the Spirit of God then the kingdom of
God is come unto you Luke says by the
finger of God Matthew says by the Spirit
of God what is the Spirit of God the
finger of God is a symbolic expression
for the Spirit of God which means the
spirit was the being that wrote the
commandments on the stone but let's get
more Bible evidence born as second
Corinthians 3 let's read first 3 2nd
Corinthians 3 verse 3 2nd Corinthians 3
we want more evidence that the spirit
wrote the law on the tables of stone he
is the finger of God we've seen that
clearly but it's good to have more
evidence because some people just don't
believe quickly do you have 2nd
Corinthians 3 verse 3 what does it say
for as much as you're manifestly
declared to be the Epistle of Christ
ministered by us we carefully now
written not with ink come on but with
the spirit of the Living God keep
reading
not in tables of stone but in fleshy
tables of the heart the Bible says the
Holy Spirit is the one who write not
only on the tables of stone but on the
tables of the heart the same power that
wrote the law on stone writes the law on
the heart somebody say Amen same power
now you're asking me well yes the
question how do I know I have the Holy
Spirit give me one word when I obey God
mm-hmm when I obey God that's the
overpowering evidence that I have the
Spirit of God I have that power
that's wrote it on strong and that
writes it on the heart so when God said
I will write my law in their hearts he
does it by the agency of the Holy Spirit
if that's clear say Amen the number one
proof that I am filled with the Spirit
of God I
God's law all right pastor do you want
some water I need to go and sleep that's
what it's okay it's okay there are two
people who asked almost the same or
related question all right let me read
all this you said in your first message
that obedience results in freedom from
fear mm-hmm how can I have freedom when
I cannot obey all right hey let's stick
with that one
that's a good question the person said
how can I have freedom when I cannot
obey here's my response let Christ obey
for you but he does he does that where
come on let Christ obey for you but
where this price have to be in order to
obey for you in you listen to what Jesus
said go to John 14 John 14 we read from
verse 8 of John 14 how can I have
freedom from fear when I cannot obey a
very good question
you have John 14 come on answer me we
live from first it was the same Philip
saith unto Him Lord show us the father
and it sufficeth us verse 9 jesus saith
unto him what have I been so long time
with you and yet hast thou not known me
Philip he that have seen me have seen
the father and how sayst thou then show
us the father next verse
believe us now not read with me that I
am in the father and the father in me
finish the verse the words that I speak
unto you I speak not of myself come on
read on but the father that dwelleth
where in me finish the verse he doeth
the works now Jesus said it is the
father in me doing what you see but in
order for that to happen Jesus had to
remain what to the father
yielded and submitted Jesus says the
father in me is the one doing what you
see now go to Galatians 2:20 that's the
father in Jesus let's look at Jesus in
the believer
remember the algebraic formula balance
on both sides Galatians 2 verse 20 find
it find it find it Galatians 2 verse 20
is the first you want to know by heart
are you there not yet are you then ah
read with me I am crucified with Christ
nevertheless I live yet not i but Christ
liveth in me and the life which I now
live in the flesh I live by the faith of
the Son of God who loved me and gave
himself for me Paul said Christ liveth
in me that is the power that enables me
to obey why is that necessary go to
Romans 8 Romans 8 let's wait for several
Romans 8 verse 7 a couple of books to
the left of Galatians
you have Romans 8:3 verse 7 with me
because the carnal mind is enmity
against God keep reading for it is not
subject to the law of God neither indeed
can be the Bible says the carnal mind
cannot obey God so that person is right
which is why you have to make a total
surrender to God and let God come into
you and direct your life when Christ
dwells in you it is the life of Christ
working in you let me explain it this
way listen to me carefully
let me pray again father and heaven
helped me they guard it if I have not
done a good job up to this point forgive
me help me to be clearer as I deal with
this most important subject that your
people may see the hope of victory over
sin in Jesus name I
amen there's a man are you following me
he walks is there camera on me is that
camera alive it oh I can't move okay
he's walking and he's walking straight
are you following me let's call this
he's walking straight now he drinks
alcohol huh after a while how does he
walk he walks this way are you following
me
why because the alcohol is wear on his
skin where it's on the inside and
working from the inside it changes the
way he walks
now you take in Jesus are you following
me
you see we were born walking that way
that's how we're born are you with me
we're born walking that way when you
take Jesus he worked from the inside and
he straightens you out are you following
me and so when you take Jesus in you he
straightens your life and so the person
who said I cannot obey give your life to
Christ 100% and Christ on the inside
will be the power to obey but that power
does not come overnight it comes by
gradual release and the release is in
this so when the devil came to Christ if
thou be the Son of God command these
stones be made bread but he answered it
is written this is the power that Christ
uses to enable you and me to obey
because a divine law cannot be obeyed by
carnal people you didn't hear what I
said
the Ten Commandments are a divine
standard a divine standard can only be
kept by divine power and so the answer
is give the life to Christ
tell Christ come into me and he will
come and you will begin to realize the
things you used to do you no longer have
a desire for them
and you keep that union going by study
and obedience to God's Word here is what
Ella white writes Christ object lessons
page 100 paragraph 1 sorry
sister April is my boss told me slow
down
Christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
1 listen carefully tell me when you're
ready
if studied and obeyed the Word of God
works in the heart subduing every unholy
attribute if studied and obeyed the Word
of God works we're in the heart subduing
every if you like to fight you always
fighting every Saturday night you go to
the bar you get drunk
you're fighting people you're fighting
yourself you're fighting when you come
to Christ he does not change your fist
are you with me he changes your heart
are you following me when this changes
everything else changes it's Christ in
us and Christ dwells in us through the
spirit filled Word the desire of Ages
page 677 paragraph 1 it is through the
word that price dwells in his followers
but Jesus says the words that I speak
unto you they are spirit and their life
that word is filled with the Spirit it
dwells in us and therein lies the power
to obey God what's the second part of
the customer do we believe in
righteousness by works when we emphasize
obedience what is the difference between
obedience and legally legalism legalism
that's a fairly good question do we
believe in righteousness by works the
answer is no if I could save myself
there was no need for Christ to die the
very fact that Christ died means no
human being can
save himself is that clear the cross of
Christ is a standing rebuke to
righteousness my words but to be saved
there is something I need to do notice I
said to be saved I've got to come to
Christ
I've got yield to him because only when
I yield that Christ can bring about this
thing called justification by faith
through the agency of the Holy Spirit so
there's no such thing as righteousness
my works
it is righteousness by faith in Jesus
Christ and because I have faith in him I
do whatever he says remember my story
about the dentist when the dentist opens
your ma tells you open your mouth why do
you open your mouth because he's a
dentist are you with me if you touch
your car to be repaired and the mechanic
said open your mouth you would wonder
what's wrong with him because he's a
mechanic he's not a dentist are you
following me but if the mechanic tells
you pop the hood you lift the hood if he
tells you start it up you start it up if
he tells you step on the brake you step
on the brake that's not repairs by works
that's repairs by faith in the mechanic
and you say Amen so when the dentist
tells you open your mouth you open your
mouth like a fish a lap a lap oh what's
that
nappy lapu lapu lapu you open your mouth
like a lapu-lapu are you following me
because you trust him when jesus says
keep the Sabbath you do it because you
trust him it's not salvation by works
it's salvation by faith in a man who's
also God legalism legalism is an attempt
to save yourself and that satanic
behavior because the legalists does not
need Jesus trying to save themselves any
action that makes Christ unnecessary is
satanic even if you dress it up with
Church legalism is an attempt to save
yourself where why do I need Jesus no
salvation by faith
and because they have faith what's the
chapter in the Bible famous for faith he
was left let's think of some examples go
to Hebrews 11 quickly to see the
connection between faith and works
Hebrews 11 quickly Hebrews 11 let's read
from verse 4
Hebrews 11 reading verse 4 do you have
that not yet he Brazil in the towards
the back of the Bible if you and James
and PD have gone too far
Hebrews 11 if you have a say Amen let's
read the first person mentioned first
for Abel read verse 4 by faith Abel
offered stopped faith and once the works
offered he did it by faith go to verse 5
by faith Enoch was translated that he
should not see death and was not found
because God had translated him for
before his translation he had this
testimony that he pleased God remembered
Jesus Johnny 29 I do always the things
that pleased him Enoch did the things
that pleased God he did it by faith look
at verse 7 by faith Noah being warned of
God of things not seen of yet moved with
fear prepared an ark to the saving of
his house by faith he worked a hundred
and twenty years to build a boat by
faith per se by faith Abraham when he
was called to go out into a place which
he should after receive for an
inheritance obeyed and he went out not
knowing whither he went abraham moved
his entire family by faith in the person
who said move faith must be connected to
Christ so when the creator tells you to
do this you do it because of who he is
[Music]
all right next question
what does the Bible say about Christmas
celebration
oh absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
now that does not mean I condemned those
who celebrate Christmas we have a lot of
information that Emma likes right things
about Christmas she does not condemn
having a Christmas tree
she recommends put gifts on the tree for
other people not for you I know you
don't like that but that's the way we
are
she said put gifts on the tree for other
people it's a good time to remind people
of Jesus she does not condemn it but you
need to understand no one knows when
Christ was born
all we know is he was born so we happy
for that the Christmas season excellent
time to evangelize because the baby in
the manger is on everybody's mind but
you don't have to celebrate Christmas it
is not what you know as a matter of fact
let's name some holidays Christmas give
me another one Easter give me another
one Valentine's Day uh-huh give me
another one mother's there god bless all
mothers Father's Day there's one in the
u.s. called sweetest day we have all
these days Ash Wednesday
Good Friday Holy Thursday unholy Tuesday
we have all these days are you with me
the only day God wants tell me that day
the Sabbath I am talking to myself
the only day God wants is the Sabbath
and we come to God and we say well wait
a minute father
how about Christmas God says no how
about Easter no Ash Wednesday no Good
Friday no you know Mother's Day no
Father's Day no uncle's day no no no
what do you want the Sabbath the song we
give him every other day except the day
he wants I must break God's heart what's
wrong with these people
let's listen
what can you advise what can you advise
us regarding too many Bible versions
today will we still get the purity of
God's truth on those different Bible
versions oh please tell us what is the
best Bible translation if you take time
and compare Bible versions you'll be
surprised how some versions cut out
several Bible verses you'll be surprised
how some versions remove the name of
Jesus when it comes to Bible versions
you have to take serious time and do
your research let me tell you this in
the Garden of Eden God said in the day
thou eatest thereof thou shalt surely
die for words
thou shalt surely die the devil said ye
shall not sure he added one word and
turned black into white or white in the
black you must believe you see the
devil's number one form of attack is
deception what does he how does he do it
he twists the word if that's the case
you must believe that the devil is
behind many of the translations that
people use in church have you ever heard
of the Queen James Bible you haven't
what version do I use there is a queen
James it was put out by homosexuals it
only changed about eight verses in
verses that have to do with
homosexuality and it's called the Queen
James because this evidence that King
James was a homosexual or he went with
men and women so they call it the Queen
James do you notice a Bible version that
you say she for God not he she you must
press a father guide me which version
should I use now when I study the Bible
my Bible is the King James but I look at
other versions to see what they say but
when it comes to overall choice my
choice
is a King James Version I said my choice
I can tell you what is my choice
ask God every Bible is not now go to
Hebrews 11 let me show you what I mean
Hebrews 11 let's read verse 21 that you
we have to stop sending questions
because I my voice will soon vanish and
I can't answer all questions I just only
God can you have Hebrews 11 verse 21 by
faith Jacob did walk when he was dying
bless both the sons of Joseph
philosophers and worship leaning what
but now they are some version there's a
version that says by faith Jacob when he
was a dying blessed both the sons of
Joseph and worship the top of his staff
that's what that is
it and worship the top of his staff so
there's a Bible version that has Jacob
worshiping something not God now you may
say that's one little verse but that's
serious this a Bible version that says
go to James chapter 5 James 5 you have
James we were in Hebrews the next book
is James I believe James 5 read verse 16
what does that say come on come on come
on read confess your faults one to
another stop there's a Bible version
that says confess your sins one to
another now the Catholic Church can use
that and say the Bible says you can
confess your sins to a priest you have
to be careful no version is perfect but
if we were to use only one version to
defend Adventist doctrines it would be
this if you have to use this one so I
recommend do your research find out
about these versions this version that
says is called the wicked Bible it says
thou shalt commit adultery hear what I
said thou shalt commit adultery it's
called the wicked Bible when they were
translating they made a mistake and left
out not so it says thou shalt commit
adultery it's called the wicked Bible
for very good reason all right next
question please enlighten us a little on
how we should deal with those who had
divorced and remarried
do we still need to worry for our ex
when you say worry for your ex what does
that mean worried for our ex was worried
but but what
when you say worried for your ex what do
you mean by worry now okay let me we
must be concerned about everybody's
salvation if you're biblically the force
and that's possible
it doesn't mean you hate your ex if the
and assuming biblically the person is
wrong you don't hate the person you
still want the person saved in the
kingdom but something happened that
broke the the marriage contract and your
Biblica mitad to remarry by the way the
guilty person cannot remember and so no
you don't hit your ex or how many X's
you have you just don't are you
following me every soul is precious in
the eyes of Christ are you following me
and so you pray for that person but
remember now you're connected to
somebody else you move on in that
direction mm-hmm but God prefers
reconciliation are you with me divorce
is the result of sin Jesus said in
Matthew 19 Moses because of the hardness
of your hearts suffered you to put away
a wives but from the beginning it was
not so
divorce is a result of sin eating meat
is a result of sin next question I hope
is easy this time what is God's purpose
for sex God's purpose for sex well I'm
too young to talk about that sort of
thing but gods this is a church
two purposes one procreation and to the
physical union between a man and his
wife it's a form of communion oneness
serious business simple it's not for
prostitution and fornication and
lesbianism homosexuality no it is for
procreation and the physical union
between a man and his wife but in the
new world there's no marriage there's no
need for sex I hope you still want to go
to the New World
what is the right thing to do if you
have come to a point wherein you must
choose between serving in the ministry
and seeking your own spiritual growth
you know that's a very serious question
because one of the ways that can cause
you to decline spiritually is working
for the church you didn't hear what I
said
Church work is one of the reasons people
have no time for Bible study oh they're
so busy being a deacon and a Deaconess
and a janitor and a treasurer they are
so busy with church work they have no
time for the Bible there are some
ministers so busy with committees they
have no time for the Bible so they have
nothing to say from the pulpit listen to
me
if church work is getting between you
and God give it up but you might as well
say Amen if Church work is getting
between you and God
give up the church work or rearrange
your priorities god of x6 let me show
you what I mean go to act 6 let the
Bible answer for you
x6 it's now 5:00 after 4:00
xyx now read for me nice and loud so I
can save my voice are you ready with my
version let's pray again quite a bit of
time has gone by father as I continue to
answer questions please help me they God
let me not drift from you you are the
source of wisdom tell me what to say and
touch the hearts of those who listening
I pray in Jesus name Amen
what book did I say what chapter read
verse 1 was a saying in those days when
the number was multiplied there arose a
murmuring of the Grecians against the
Hebrews because their widows were
neglected in the daily ministration now
this is the early church the church
where the dead were raised and the sick
were healed and demons cast out when
rich members gave to the church to give
to the poor the Jewish women were
getting more than the Hebrew than the
Greek women because the Jewish were Jews
and the Greeks were Gentiles coming into
the church so it is discrimination verse
2 then the twelve called the multitude
of the disciples unto them and said what
it is not reason come on that we shall
leave the Word of God and serve tables
stop now who is the twelve Peter James
John all the Twelve Apostles Peter said
looked it makes no sense for us to leave
this to go handle little problems in the
church it's not sensible verse three
wherefore lookie out brethren what seven
men of seven men of one honest report
come on full of them and whom we may
appoint over this matter now read verse
four nice and clear and loud
but we will give ourselves continually
and to the ministry these men knew what
the priority was the word not deciding
who sits where should a carpet be blue
on this side pink on that side how far
should this table be up Peter said look
you deal with that we have higher
priorities the word find seven men bring
in to us we unlike them let them do the
work the word is our priority my brother
and sister whoever wants to be a
preacher this must be your priority
if Church work gets in the way of this
cut back on church work or cut it out
next question now I pass I can answer
all those questions because I have to
stop I'll take that do you have one in
your hand what does that say how
important is the century service Oh God
Psalm 77 Psalm 77
how important is this sanctuary service
well any Adventist can answer they're
absolutely important without a sanctuary
we cannot understand the gospel as well
as we might Psalm 77 do you have that
all right some of you don't have me we
just read one verse read verse 13 by way
or God come on is in a sanctuary stop
that's where we go to understand sin
Redemption justification sanctification
that's where we go to understand the
plan of salvation the sanctuary that is
what sets the Adventist church apart
from all of the
it's teachings on the sanctuary the most
important first for Adventist teaching
is Daniel 8:14 which says this and he
said unto me unto 2300 days then shall
the sanctuary be claims that's the most
important Bible first for us
here's Ellen White great controversy
page 409 paragraph 1 this scrip
let me let you write it down great
controversy just put GC page four or
nine paragraph one here's what it says
the scripture which above all others had
been both the foundation and the central
pillar of the Advent movement was the
declaration unto two thousand and three
hundred days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed I urge you as individuals
embarked upon a study of the sanctuary
your eyes will be opened you will
understand the gospel much more clearly
your life will change Christ will take
on a different aspect to you it is all
in the sanctuary remember the sanctuary
on earth was based on the pattern in
heaven there is a sanctuary in heaven
next question is it ok to sing worldly
songs which is holy the lyrics of the
melody why is there so much in
inconsistencies among SDA hmm
is it ok to sing secular songs that
would depend now the national anthem of
the Philippines is a secular song of the
United States England whatever the
secular songs but they have deep deep
meaning to the citizens of that country
very deep meaning and Jesus said render
to Caesar the things that are Caesar's
so we must as far as possible give what
is required of society but not the
singing that we see on tea
the Beyonce Lady Gaga Manny Pacquiao oh
no no
no no no no no uh-uh that's the devil's
music those things are not written to
glorify God movies are not made to
glorify God not even those called the
passion or whatever movies are made to
make money those songs are written to
make money you wanna sing sing a hymn by
the way singing hymns is one way to
resist temptation you don't believe me
if you tempted to sing tonight start
singing would you be free from the
burden of sin this power in the blood
power in the blood
sing that and see what happens to the
temptation it goes down but if you sing
something by I don't know who is the pop
star in the Philippines you know I don't
know Jose whatever his name is you sing
something by him then the temptation
goes up the Bible says if a then be
risen with Christ seek those things
which are above where Christ sitteth on
the right hand of God I'll go further
you should have no interest in
Manchester United and Arsenal and
there's the Los Angeles Lakers those are
the things of the world the Bible says
love not the world neither the things of
the world soccer basketball boxing horse
those are the things of the world soon
you want to sing singing him if the
principle is to obey and keep the server
mm-hmm does it mean that seventh-day
Adventist people are the only one that
is going to be saved no no no no no
those who will be saved will be obedient
no this obedient person will enter the
pearly gates are you following me
no disobedient person will enter the
pearly gates pray for me
know not only Adventist now there are
some people who died having never heard
about the Sabbath go to acts 16 at 16 No
go to John 15 John 15 John 15 let's read
verse 22 the question is will only
Adventist go to heaven the answer is no
but I said only the obedient will go to
heaven John 15 22 what does that first
say nice and clean loud if I had not
come and spoken unto them they had not
had since the prices saying when a man
does not know God does not charge him
with sin there are people who obeyed God
based on the light that they had never
kept the Sabbath they never knew their
be in the kingdom but we have the
advantage of the writings of the Prophet
Ellen White she tells us the journey to
heaven takes seven days in that journey
we will spend one sabbath in heaven in
the inn in space which means when we
finally get to the city
everyone who enters the gates will be a
Sabbath keeper mm-hmm
God has it all planned no one can enter
the gates who has not kept all Tana you
didn't kill him on the earth but you are
faithful you will make up for it on the
journey to heaven you need Ellen White
to give that kind of information or the
church hazard
can you say Amen for LOI I love that
woman I defend her until I die all right
it will have but let me see even though
I said not all either this will be saved
I must also tell you that a duelists are
the only ones who defend the law of God
and the problem with the world is the
violation of God's law that's why the
third angel's message is the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus Christ God needs how do you
identify God's church listen and the
dragon was wroth with the woman and went
to make war with the remnant of her seed
what woman is the dragon angry with
which keep the commandments of God
mm-hmm so God has a people that defends
his law that's the 70 AD for this church
it will have free will in heaven will we
still be capable of sinning no that's a
good question that's a good question now
God does not want to be served by robots
are you following me will we have free
will in heaven yes but I want you to
understand something clearly follow me
when God created the earth the first
time when did he make man six last he
made a perfect world first are you with
me what did I just say he made a perfect
world first then he brought what kind of
people into it perfect people let me say
that again God made a perfect world from
day one to the morning of day six when
everything was in place a perfect world
a sinless world then he made two perfect
people and they sin this time now will
God make a new heaven and a new earth
yes or no yes but before he makes that
world he reverses the process what is he
making first the people he's perfecting
us first now through the gospel of Jesus
Christ he is asking us do you want to
live in a world where there is no sin
that's what he's asking and we say yes
by getting sin of our lives now when we
make the choice to get sin out of our
lives God says now I'll put you in a
sinless world because you have chosen to
live in us in this world so when we get
in that world we have already chosen not
to have anything to do a sin and God
seals us in that decision that's why he
that is unjust let him be unjust still
here it is filthy let him be filthy
still he that is holy let him be holy
still he that is righteous it is
decisions we made and God says is that
your decision yes he seals us so
there'll be no more sin because we're
choosing that now God is a force it on
us he tuned we choose it now when he has
perfected us he comes for us takes us to
heaven for a thousand years according to
revelation 20 then he comes back
destroys the wicked then he creates a
new heaven and a new earth and this time
we will stand right there and see him do
it nobody's excited the first time God
made the heaven and the earth Adam and
Eve were not made they open their eyes
they it was this time the redeemed will
stand somewhere in the universe and
watch Christ create a new heaven and
new earth will see it all right next
question
before I think in Daniel 10 my first
stop in Daniel 10 verse 13 how was the
Prince of Persia equated to Satan
alright okay how did we come up to the
event
yes all right Daniel writes in verse 13
but Michael one of the chief Prince's
came to help me and I remained there
with the Kings at first enough Gabriel
said but the prince of the kingdom of
Persia withstood me one in 20 days
Daniel 10 verse 12 now you have to
reason that's why reasoning is important
now Gabriel is the highest angel in
heaven are you with me
alright when you read the Bible every
time a man has seen an angel the man was
scared are you following me or a woman
when the angel appeared to Mary she was
afraid the angel said fear not when the
angel appeared to Sakurai's in the
temple the father John the Baptist he
was afraid the angel said fear not when
the angel appeared to manoa the father
of sampson he had to say fair norm when
the angel appeared to Balaam Balaam fell
on his horse office or scared to death
when the angel appeared to Joshua Joshua
fell on his face every time an angel has
appeared to human beings the human
beings have been terrified so a human
being could not resist gabriel are you
with me it had to be on spirit being and
the only power that could resist gabriel
would be the power of satan not the
prince of persia' because the prince of
persia is just a man you follow the
reasoning it had to have been a
spiritual being and since Gabel is the
highest being only satan could have
resisted gabriel all right it's there a
connection of the 1888 righteousness by
faith message by Elder Jones and now
their webinar - the project of pastor
Ted Wilson of revival and Reformation
well revival and Reformation and the
third angels message go hand in hand
because when the third angels message is
preached as it should along with the
latter rain we will have tremendous
revival and Reformation now we have two
things revival Reformation revival means
to come alive again re is again v4 is
life you come alive again when you come
alive again
then Reformation follows means a
different behavior a different contact
and the power that brings that about is
the Word of God is the word of God that
brings about revival and that brings
about Reformation
and in these last days we have something
called present truth now in every age
there has been present truth in every
age in our age the present truth is the
30 angels message which is righteousness
by faith righteousness is obedience by
faith trusting in the merits of Jesus
Christ and so yes elder Wilson's
wrathful revival Reformation the 30
angels message yes they go hand in hand
they cannot be separated
why did Jesus find forbid Mary from
touching him in John 20 verse 17 well he
well he evented or he even asked Thomas
to touch him yes okay what's with Mary
and what we Thomas okay that they have
different way of treatment that's fine
that's fine now when Mary saw Jesus in
the in the garden John 20 he had not yet
gone to his father for the father to
accept his sacrifice are you with me so
the Greek word for touch-me-not
means don't keep holding on to me it's
not as she didn't touch him at all he's
saying look I have to go are you
following me don't keep all that I have
to go so the father can say yes I accept
your sacrifice
when Thomas touched him he had already
gone and come back are you following me
so Thomas could do whatever he did but
Jesus didn't tell Mary don't touch me at
all
he seems they don't keep holding on to
me that's what the Greek means because I
have to go but I'll be back all right
next question after the fall of Lucifer
ass covering cherub mm-hmm who took his
place Gabriel what can we find where can
we find this in the Bible now you want
there's a lot of things you don't find
explicitly stated in the Bible but
listen to what Gabriel tells Zacharias
but before we read that listen to the
work of a cherub Ezekiel 28 read verse
14 let's see what the cherub does is
equal 28 verse 14
now the Bible is describing Lucifer Luke
20 verse 14 is 425 we've been going at
this how long now hour and a half you
know the Bible says temperance and all
things that means answering questions it
really means okay my haven't told last
question by the Sanhedrin so I have to I
have to hope to be alright do you have
Ezekiel 28 read verse 14 for me here's
what the Bible says about Lucifer come
on now at the anointed cherub that
covereth and I have said he saw now that
verse doesn't say though I the anointed
cherubim cherub is single its signals
out Lucifer as the one who have stood
right next to God the anointed cherub
that covereth the cherub stood right
next to God and covered him with his
wing are you with me now go to Luke 1
listen to what Gabriel tells the father
of John the Baptist or the man who would
be the father of John the Baptist keep
in mind the cherub stands right next to
God to cover him listen to what Gabriel
tells Zacharias Luke 1 let's read 18 and
19 of Luke 1 have you found it my
friends read for me what does they say
and Zacharias said unto the angel
whereby shall I know this for I am an
old man and my wife was stricken in
years the angel told Zacharias you and
your wife will have a child
Zacharias says I am to all my wife is
too old how will this happen
he had doubt listen to Gabriel in verse
19 and the angel answering said unto Him
what I am Gabriel that was our stand in
the presence of God store what is he
saying about himself
he is the angel that stands right next
to God but we read in ezekiel 28:14
that's where Lucifer was
but we know Lucifer was cast out you put
two and two together Gabriel - two
Lucifer's place now you read having
looked at the Bible you read this out of
ATF it's 693 paragraph three desire of
Ages 693 paragraph three are you ready
the mighty angel who stands in God's
presence occupying the position from
which Lucifer fell came to the side of
Christ
it was Gabriel who came to Christ in the
Garden of Gethsemane when he was
bleeding from his skin Luke 22 verse 43
they appeared an angel from heaven unto
Him strengthening him it was Gabriel he
was the one who took the position
vacated by Lucifer all right I am the
twelve this is the end my brothers and
sisters let me urge you from my heart in
the presence of heaven and earth make
the study of the Bible a matter of
greater importance than physical foody
that's no joke there is deception coming
on this world that only those who know
the world can tell the difference go to
2nd Corinthians chapter 11 let me show
you what I mean 2nd Corinthians chapter
second Corinthians chapter 11 are you
there read verse 14 ones that say and no
Marvel come on for Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of light now
which means the greatest deceptions are
spiritual not political or economic the
greatest deceptions are spiritual
Satan transforms himself into an angel
of light now look at John chapter 1
verse 9 John 1:9 we were in 2nd
Corinthians 11 we go to John 9 read
verse 9 of John chapter 1 that was the
true light which lighteth every man that
cometh into the world how was the light
described the true light which means
what there's a false light but light now
go back to 2nd Corinthians 11 we read 14
again then we go to 15 and be shocked
2nd Corinthians 11 verse 14 and 15 read
with me nice and clear and no Marvel for
Satan himself is transformed into an
angel of light read verse 15 therefore
it is no great thing if his ministers
also be transformed into the world
ministers of righteousness whose end
shall be according which means in these
last days you cannot tell
your eyes are cleared up by this if you
don't believe me just go on the
television I mean that YouTube and just
what some short services led by prophets
and you wonder how can intelligent
people believe that there is a church in
South Africa with the members at a
certain point in the service they run
out lie down on the ground as fat eating
grass you are a youtuber say Church at
each grass they run up many of them
young people studying for degrees in
university they run out and start eating
grass the Bible says in Psalm 104 first
verse 15 he causes the grass to grow for
the cattle are you following me the
evening grass now how do people do that
deceptions to me academic degrees are no
defense against deception study this I
want it recorded in heaven that on
December 16 25 minutes to 5:00 I told
this beloved audience study God's Word
teach it to your children it is not a
decent life that qualifies us for God's
kingdom it's not a decent life that
protects us from deception it is a
knowledge of the Word of God
applied in the life this-this-this as
God reveals it to you what should your
response be give me one word or B let's
pray stand up with me
let's sing 26 I love that song wonderful
words of life and they're right here now
I want you to sing where is sister
organist we don't have a musician rather
we sing okay we'll just sing it without
music see oh okay
all right sister god bless you for
running in the church comments okay all
right god bless that system we thank God
for music but remember what
Nebuchadnezzar said now if you be ready
when you hear the sound of the cornet
flute harp sackbut psaltery and dulcimer
all kinds of music music goes both ways
you can draw you to God I'll draw you to
Satan you have to choose wisely ah there
we go singing see them over again to me
wonderful words of love
let me more of a beauty see wonderful
words of love words of life words the
life and beauty sleep faith and
beautiful words wonderful words
wonderful words of love
wonderful words of light price a blessed
one is your wonderful words of love see
my little doll laughing poor wonderful
words of love
also freely given will be us forever
beautiful words wonderful words
wonderful words false life beautiful
words wonderful words wonderful words of
life
sweetly improve the gospel call
wonderful lists of life come on singing
all for pardon and peace world wonderful
words of life Jesus holy Savior Jesus
holy Savior sanctified forever beautiful
words wonderful words wonderful words of
life beautiful words wonderful words
wonderful words of
the fight for a study God's Word commit
some to memory if a young person commits
your education to God's glory if a young
person do not date outside of the church
after this home page 67 paragraph one to
connect with an unbeliever is to place
yourself on Satan's ground you grieve
the spirit of God and forfeit his
protection be faithful to God be
faithful to one another make life easy
one for the other
don't let your presence cause someone
else to be miserable just be a blessing
just by your presence have a word of
encouragement to speak
lift up someone who's downtrodden don't
be a professional critic finding out
people's sins is not a spiritual gift
encourage them
yes we must rebuke sin but don't go
looking for sin because the same jebal
looking for you become I love you thank
you for treating me nicely thanks for
loving the word god bless you and
wherever you are if I come across your
mind please say Lord put your words in
that man's mouth now may the grace of
our Lord Jesus Christ and the love of
God and the Fellowship of the Holy
Spirit be with us now and forevermore
let God's people say Amen and amen god
bless you if we don't meet on this side
let us make every effort by God's grace
to meet on the other side please be
seated
I'll give the time to dr. de Castro to
say something before we finish please be
seated
Oh can you take this off here I don't
know how to tell you what to say
it might just I'm I'm too emotional
right now because so many things I would
just again we want to thank everyone
first of all it is God's leading that
somebody was impressed by God to invite
pastor Randy so we want to thank you for
coming here please come back we went to
him invite you again to come back here
yes
[Applause]
I gave them to dr. Jamie Lou de Castro
because it was the one who organized
this this program but as a pastor of us
Adventist Church
thank you very much to your group CCC
and the rest about the staff thank you
it's been a wonderful time that we spent
for the whole week
make sure you will continue to study
God's Word as he has told us by the way
we still have one portion of the program
which is our intercessory prayer and I'm
waiting for pastor Walker pastor Walker
can you come here I have something very
important don't go please
I want him to stand here because we have
been because we have been busy every
night pastor Walker has been our
associate pastor of Posse Adventist
Church last night he was ordained full
plates in the ministry congratulation
pastor pass walk i we were not able to
go and witness your ordination but just
to tell you that our hearts are with you
we were praying for you and we want you
to succeed in this church as you have
been succeeding in previous districts
where you were assigned so we will
continue to pray for your ministry and
please continue to be a loving pastores
we have known you and continue to be
successful in the ministry we are happy
for his ministry so as you can see the
people love you and Michelle so please
continue to stay here we don't want you
to go anywhere as soon as that
thank you for your ministry
and may God bless you maybe I'll give
you some time to talk for a short time
okay last night I actually intended not
to to invite our leaders here because I
know they are doing a very important job
here in our church and so last night I
only mentioned my response to God's call
as a full full-fledged minister as I
told the people who were present last
night that together with my wife we will
give our all to God in respond to the
calling that he has entrusted on our
shoulders and I would like to to say
this so pastor at this church that you
are part of that journey that we are
doing right now as ministers thank you
so all the leaders here in the church
pastor tolentino for his leadership in
leading us in nurturing us young
ministers in the pastoral staff and so
for being a full-fledged pastor I don't
feel I don't I deserve that but only
because of God's grace he has given
given us or given me this calling to
serve him with all my heart with all my
soul and with all my mind so I would
like to thank pastor at this church for
bearing with me I am still a young
minister and I want to grow with you as
you can see I am growing here and I hope
that we can we will grow together in the
service of the Lord and please continue
to pray for me
my wife and the pastoral staff family
gathered SS all okay so since we have
been listening to God's Word the whole
week and I'm sure that most of you were
here and also this afternoon we have
been listening to pastor Randy skis
[Music]
messages at this point in time so
continue our intercessory service we
will be proceeding to the dropping of
our prayers of request and thanks then
after that we will be I think or some
somebody or somebody has prepared a song
then after that we will be doing our
testimonials as our usual program here
and so maybe we can hear you will hear a
piano while we drop our mean prayer of
thanks and prayer of request we can
begin dropping it right now
thank you
[Music]
I want to know if the Bolero family is
here
I think we need to proceed to our
testimonials
so who will be the first one to share
your testimony about God's love gets